[Music]
so I'm very happy to be here I'm very
excited to talk to you about natural
language processing and the subtitle of
this talk means that I'll try to give
more general overview of tools and
techniques that you can use so I won't
delve into details that much but rather
give you started something to start with
and to look for more information but
before we go forward
she's welcomes the bass on the stage
[Applause]
okay I'd like to start with an
introduction and let me first introduce
myself so my name is Sebastien Jojo I
come originally from Krakow sorry but I
live in Munich at the moment and I work
at clicks which is a cool startup and
we'll building a private browser so a
browser with built-in anti tracking
anti-phishing and a private search so if
you use this cool thing called the
Internet but I'm not a fan of sharing
your personal data with big companies
boy do I have a product for you also
recently with a quiet gostrey some of
you might know it's an anti tracking
extension and together we're working on
building the best anti tracking
technology so I have a couple of those
guys let's say if you matter now ask a
good question you get one I define a
good question as one that I can ease the
answer and yeah I have plenty of those
you don't have to ask questions just
come say hello and you get one okay so
if you feel a sudden urge to tweet
during this presentation this is my
rather unimaginative handle also if you
want to say hello after the conference
it's a good way to contact me now what
is natural language processing it's very
hard to define because it's very general
our field of knowledge but if I
absolutely had to I would say this is a
set of techniques and methods that let
you transform raw language there
into a machine-readable representation
and the other way around so for example
Martine told us about machine
translation in this good example when
you're doing both things so we start
with the raw data in one language you go
into an intermediate representation and
then you generate output in another
language why it's natural language
processing important well every day we
produce a ridiculous amount of data much
of the data is actually language we use
messengers we use social media and so on
so extracting valuable information from
that's unstructured data it's very
useful thing to do and it is useful for
consumers because you can have products
like Amazon echo or Google home which
has been promised by sci-fi for a long
time and finally we're starting to
deliver it so we won't get a jetpack
anytime soon but you'll be able to talk
to your microwave if you want now why
it's not language processing heart well
our language by natural language I mean
the language we speak language we write
the language we sign and it is a natural
phenomenon which means that it evolved
and with every product of evolution it
is more about being good enough
rather than perfect and language is far
from perfect one of the most annoying
feature of language as far as NLP is
concerned is its ambiguity so language
is naturally ambiguous for example you
can have something like semantic
ambiguity when the same word can mean
different things or you can have
phonetic ambiguity or syntactic
ambiguity in this case are in the first
sentence time is the subject and flies
is the verb and in the second sentence
fruit flies are the subject and like is
the verb so it's even hard for a human
process instantly and it's very
demanding for a machine
now language evolves and it continues to
evolve which means that no dictionary
will ever ever be exhaustive and oxford
dictionary is updated every year and
these are the words that has been added
this year and I think they speak volumes
about time we live in we have worse
joycie miss millennium for worst hate
monger post truth and Pagano phobia
which is the irrational fear of beards
assuming the Kabini irrational fear of
beard now language is very flexible very
unstructured but on the other hand the
implicit rules that we use and sometimes
we don't even realize the rules are
there for example English has a very
constrained order of adjectives so here
we go this opinion size age shape color
origin material purpose and then known
so you can have an ugly large old brown
English tweed hunting jacket somewhere
in your wardrobe or organize a big fat
greek wedding but if you use any other
permutation to a native speaker you
gonna sound a bit like this famous
little green Jedi Master now some
language are harder than than others
every language has its rule I won't
attempt to read this word but it's a
real one and knowing those rules is
essential for effective language
processing so on once one side language
is unstructured and flexible on the
other side is very constrained in some
respects fortunately we have a lot of
tools and methods to deal with that so
I'm going to give a quick overview of
the library's methods tools you can use
and outline the process of approaching
NLP problems so above you can see the
general pipeline of approaching most
nuts language processing problems of
course
I cannot give you a one golden golden
rule to approach everything speech
recognition is going to be different for
from text classification and text
classification is going to be different
from machine translation so many aspects
of NLP and each is going to be a bit
different but you usually start with a
data set so we need to get it from
somewhere and there are plenty of
resources you can use data repositories
such as Kegel or data at word they have
already Python SDK so you can access it
directly also there's this github repo
on NLP datasets so we can use that to
find your data set if you're looking for
linguistic resources are usually a good
good place to go is a website of an
academic team a university and so on so
for example Stanford NLP has a ton of
resources for English mostly then if
you're interested in Polish there's the
second website and also you can search
github so there's this replica awesome
NLP I can also look for say awesome
polish NLP and you find resources for
Polish and other languages as well now
you're free to build your own data set
of course although it's it's a bit
demanding with some NLP problems for
example if you wanted to text
classification
it's a supervised learning problem so we
need to label the data set which is
generally difficult and requires a lot
of efforts but Twitter github or
Wikipedia have API so you can access and
you can build your own data set which is
a very valuable contribution to to the
academic community and community of
programmers as well
second thing you usually do
as he transformed the data somehow so
this is just this is just text
transformations so you can normalize
text meaning his strip of emojis or
hashtags or user mentions and I think
you don't need for the particular tasks
so it obviously depends on the problem
then you can do stomach
semmen or limit ization which basically
reduces your dictionary and then you can
add some information like part of speech
tagging has been shown quite recently to
improve neural machine translation so
sometimes adding disinformation is also
effective tools you can use plain Python
so you can go quite a long way with
regular expressions in general and
functions like lower or strip or split
and so on our UNIX command line is also
quite useful for this pre-processing
part then you have an ltk for stemming
or limit associations better for
educational purposes
I wouldn't use it in production that
much a nice modern alternative is Spacey
now this is what tweets look like in
general so this is an example from one
of my side projects and you can see that
you might want to need to strip the user
mentions to strip some punctuation or
emojis and so on how the text can look
like this as well so there's no one
regular expression that will work every
time this is an example of stemming and
limit ization I would generally
recommend to limit eyes words this is a
quote from Monty Python and in the
middle you have the lemon sized version
and then you can see that stemming is
generally more brutal so we just chopped
off the endings and very rather simple
algorithm and limit ization is more
linguistically informed it's a bit more
sophisticated of course more time
consuming as well now every task can be
demanding for example this is a birth
the ordinary senses in English now you
might not know that Buffalo has three
meanings one is the name of a city in
the US I think and then the name of the
animal which is technically a bison and
also a verb which means to intimidate so
passing a sentence can be are difficult
now encoding is the process transforming
the data from text some numerical
representation and there's plenty of
ways to do it you can use for example
tf-idf or one-hot encoding or if you
want to hang out with the cool kids it
means you want to use words medics or
some variant of word embeddings which is
very clever algorithm that lets you go
from texts from words to real valued
vectors and it has this interesting
property that words which are similar
semantically are going to be mapped
close to each other in this high
dimensional vector space so this is a
very useful feature and you can go a
long way just using a pre trained word
vectors pre-trained where vectors and
then building a simple classifier on top
of that or using any linear models just
with those pre trained embeddings if you
want to train your own you can do it of
course so this Jennsen very nice topic
modeling our library and we have the
creator of Jenson giving a keynote
tomorrow this fast X from Facebook which
uses slightly different algorithm takes
into account our sub words so it's more
morphologically in Forman than this
graph which builds those vectors using
matrix factorization one example is
information retrieval at clicks so the
way we do it our index is basically a
dictionary that map's queries to
websites and when we get a new query
from the user we want to find similar
queries in our index and serve
are the specific website and the way we
do this is we map it into a certain
bedding space and then we look for
nearest neighbors so it's an extremely
simple approach our works surprisingly
well for this task of course we it's not
an exhaustive search we use we use an
approximate algorithm this library from
Spotify which is called and Noi and it
enables you to look for approximate
nearest neighbors I'm sorry for my voice
I'm a bit sick okay now if you want to
of course it's an optional step once you
have this representation you can
visualize it and there's a talk tomorrow
about visualizing word matting's so I
won't do that instead I'm gonna
visualize tf-idf vectors so I trained
them on Project Gutenberg and we we
gonna see that in a minute
of course if you want to visualize high
dimensional space you're gonna first
want to convert it to more
human-friendly
number of dimensions such as 2 or 3 and
then you can visualize it so to to do it
you can use PCA or t-sne so algorithms
for that lets you reduce the
dimensionality of the space and you can
use scikit-learn for that and then
Muttalib for our visualization it's very
simple so the example I told you about
itis train tf-idf X's on books from
Project Gutenberg and then you can
visualize it using the word cloud
package from Python
I think the backs for the conference
were also designed using that that
library and then can you guess the book
not so difficult yes and then it's a
very simple approach but you can already
extract some information from it for
example on the right you have the first
story of Shirley
Holmes and dr. Watson you can see the
Holmes is very prominent in it and he
can't even find Watson and then this
Hound of the Baskervilles on the left
and then you can see Holmes but Watson
already starts to appear so the
relationship is developing and he can
also use this dimensionality reduction
so these are tf-idf vectors that are
mapped to a two dimensional space and
you can see for example that shapes we
place are very close to each other
there's a strong cluster near the top of
the picture when you can when you have
Jane Austen and Charlotte Bronte very
close to each other on the right you
have philosophers so this Plato and
Aristotle in the middle we have a poetry
cluster and then bottom rights as
Dostoyevsky sad and alone in the corner
so it's a very simple algorithm you just
construct tf-idf vectors and then you
visualize it in 2d or I can also you're
gonna already see some interesting
relationships then once you have the
embedding or other film of real valued
representations you can train the model
and you can use basically the old-school
machine learning models but again if you
want to be cool
they probably gonna use deep learning
and thus plenty of architectures like
for machine translation there's this
sequence the sequence architecture for
finding similar items as this Siamese
architecture thus plenty of options one
of the basic building blocks is our
recurrent neural networks in particular
LST n and also the the by Durant by
directional variant one mechanism that
like to draw me a well attention to this
attention and that enables you first of
all it will improve the performance of
the model but also it lets you inspect
the model a bit so we can visualize
which
parts of the data the model uses to
solve a particular NLP task these are
tools you can use so for those
old-school models I must lose
scikit-learn and 4-d Blanton for deep
learning I prefer carrots because it's
very easy to learn spacy has a ton of
pre-trained models as well so it's I
would say very useful one example of a
side project I did was hate speech
detection from tweets and basically I
trained a deep allison model and also a
very simple linear model on top of fast
exam Eddings and it turns out that the
simpler model is almost instant to train
but the performance is only slightly
worse so it didn't really pay off to use
the more complicated version I'd like to
propose some best practices of course
he's a best practices according to me my
personal experience and the experience
of people I worked with and the first
thing I want to say it is very important
to define the problem you're trying to
solve so there are three main components
of any ml task first actual task then
the data are you using and then the
metric you using to see how well you're
doing and depending on how you choose
any of those you're going to end up with
a completely different problem so pay
attention to how you define the task
what data you use and what metric used
to score your model second thing are
assumptions we know that every model is
wrong and some models are useful and
it's very important to remember what
assumptions you're making before you
even build the model so how you process
the data what information you retain
what information you reject and so on
and for me the most important part is
motivation so keeping in mind what
question you're trying to answer
the stakeholders who are you going to
report to and what are you actually
trying to solve second thing is to
inspect the data and there's a couple of
problems you can bump into first data
can be just too noisy to learn anything
and that maybe may not be your fault
because a lot of data sets are actually
crowd-sourced and annotators are human
they make mistakes so then they can
introduce a lot of noise through the
data set second problem is data set can
be ordered so remember to just shuffle
it randomly before you start training it
and especially before you split it into
train and test data set then in balance
this is important for classification
problems so for example in this hates
with hate speech detection problem it
may be hard to believe that the majority
of tweets actually did not contain hate
speech so it's it's important to keep in
mind that the classes are never going to
be to have the same number of examples
in your in your data then again you can
simply have too few examples to learn
anything so the data might be too sparse
and also if you're working with
different languages you cannot bump into
problems with encoding avoid reinventing
the wheel so I gave you some examples of
libraries you can use if you absolutely
can't use other people Scout at least
reuse your own so extract the functions
you use often into modules and then we
use them for other projects this is my
personal advice so choose the simplest
tool the simplest method possible that
will solve the problem so Catherine told
us about this coggle approach when he
basically built an ensemble of 1 million
models and then you can
really you start because you can't
interpret it so start very small start
with the data said you know or start
with a model that you can control and
the model you can understand and the
model you can build on so once it breaks
you're gonna see it you're gonna know
and at which point something went wrong
if you start with very complicated model
on a data set you don't know this simply
will be too many parameters and you
won't know what went wrong and then if
you use other libraries if you use other
people's code don't be afraid to open
the black box don't be afraid to look
inside to inspect the code and to
actually understand how they do what
what they do so then the technical
advice I do a lot of work in the
terminal and I think it's a great tool
pre-processing organizing your data and
so on what's the learning curve is a bit
steep but it pays to actually know the
UNIX utilities well final piece of
advice get your work out there so if you
do something like writing your own Linux
kernel it's a great conversation starter
but in some circles it's also a great
conversation stopper in most circles but
if you work with machine learning or
with NLP it's very easy to explain the
problem in layman's terms so take
advantage of that write a blog post
other readme to your personal project
and I want to leave you with the words
of Andrei Carpathia whose blog posts
introduced me and I'm sure many others
to NLP and he said do good work
communicate sit properly
people would notice and good things will
happen thank you
[Applause]
so thank you so much we have time for a
few questions
this one in the back I have a question I
don't know if you will be able to answer
because it it is about the information
retrieval that you talk or because this
is pretty much the task of your your
search engine to provide results so
could you elaborate a little more on the
information which we value you used so
the way we do it is we have our own web
index though I think is about 2 billion
pages at the moment we focus on the
German part of the Internet's but we are
already expanding to 2 other markets and
what we have I'm gonna simplify it very
much but how it works is we have this
index which are queries with already
seen and they point to websites so when
we do the first we want to fetch the
first say 10,000 pages to serve a
particular queries and then we rerun it
and finally we serve just free queries
so the way we do that first step is we
map this user query and all the queries
in our index to a shirt embedding space
and we use fast X for that and then we
search for nearest neighbors neighbors
using this approximate nearest neighbor
algorithm which I won't explain now but
the library is called annoy it's from
Spotify and this very good explanation
so it lets you its it lets you find
nearest neighbors in a very large data
set and usually the number of similar
queries we would consider for that
initial step would be like four point
million and then we want to find nearest
neighbors in that so we we wouldn't be
able to find it in real time quick
enough and latency is very important in
in information retrieval because you
don't want to annoy the user basically
yeah so you work around pretty much the
start with comparing the queries right
so you don't don't start from the
scratch and did you do anything with
indexing for example the contents when
you do the reindex thing or researching
so you have some similar queries it's
anything happening to the content on the
sites or is it at just the next step I
don't work out search so the short
answer is I don't know but I think it's
based on user queries only at the moment
okay thank you
anyone else or yeah are some language is
easier to process than the others or NLP
is language agnostic it's definitely not
language agnostic agnostic so for
example this limit ization or part of
speech tagging is especially important
for highly inflected languages like
polish so I recently tried to translate
a sentence and Google Translate and in
Polish it was yeah oh no no sorry yes
informatics console there was no
information about the program and this
translates to English as she is a
computer scientist but Google translated
this as he is a computer scientist so
bit awkward but it probably comes from
the bias in the data so you want to
introduce that information because some
languages have mechanism that do not
exist in other languages look in English
you can usually specify the gender in
the problem right and in Polish that the
information is in the verb or in the
noun and in general highly inflected the
highly inflected language more tricky
and I think the next presentation is
exactly about that ok thanks so much
we'll talk
I think I'm legally obliged to show you
this slide as well okay you're going to
stay with us for the whole day yes and
tomorrow okay so again you can read this
button somewhere at the corridor and
talk to him
you